Christina Couch: Okay, it looks like we're,
we're ready to go here. Panelists, are you
all ready to do this?
Tanya Ballard Brown: Ready.
Christina Couch: Hey, great! Okay, wonderful.
Welcome to all of the attendees who are here.
There are quite a few of you. We are thrilled
to have you. Welcome to the MIT Communications
Forum.
Christina Couch: So this is our first virtual
event. We're really thrilled to be using this
format to reach a broader audience, so sincerely,
thank you to every single person who's here
for making that happen.
Christina Couch: We have what is bound to
be a really fascinating panel tonight. We
were so excited that all of our speakers and
moderator were available. So I will give everybody
a little bit of info about how this event
will work. We're going to have roughly 45
minutes of moderated Q and A followed by
Christina Couch: Sorry, followed by about
45 minutes of audience Q and A. I'll be reading
that audience Q and A out loud to our speakers.
So if you have a question, do not put it in
the chat. Drop it in the Q and A box below.
Christina Couch: There are a lot more attendees
than there are speakers. So we will try to
get to as many questions as is humanly possible.
Christina Couch: This event is being recorded.
We plan to add some closed captioning and
we're going to post it on our MIT forum, MIT
Communications Forum website at Commforum.mit.edu.
Christina Couch: If you would like to see
more events just like this one, please sign
up for our mailing list. That is also at Commforum.mit.edu.
I will put that link in the chat as soon as
this intro is over.
Christina Couch: I promise you we will not
spam you. We only send emails related to our
events each year. We only have about six and
so you won't be receiving too much email from
us.
Christina Couch: One last thing, we would
not be able to make events like this happen
without generous support from sponsors. A
very special thank you to Radius at MIT, they've
supported many of our events.
Christina Couch: They've been a phenomenal
partner for making events like this happen,
and a special thanks to the MIT Governance
Lab. We're working with them for the first
time, and we're thrilled for their support.
So without further ado, we have a spectacular
lineup.
Christina Couch: I'm excited to introduce
our speakers and our moderator.
Christina Couch: First up, we have Dr. Shardé
M. Davis. She is an assistant professor in
the Department of Communication at the University
of Connecticut, and she's the creator of #BlackInTheIvory.
Christina Couch: Dr Davis's research examines
the way Black women leverage communication
in the sister circle to invoke collective
identity,
Christina Couch: erect and fortify the boundaries
around their home place, and backfill the
necessary resources to return to a white / male
dominated spaces in society.
Christina Couch: Dr. Davis also serves as
the Immediate Past Chair of the African American
Communication and Culture Division of the
National Communications Association.
Christina Couch: Welcome, Dr. Davis. Dr. James
Mickens is the Gordon Mackay Professor of
Computer Science at Harvard University. His
research focuses on the performance, security,
and robustness of large scale distributed
web services.
Christina Couch: Prior to his work at Harvard,
Dr Mickens spent six years at Microsoft Research,
where he worked in the Distributed Systems
Group. He is currently on the board of directors
at the Berkman-Klein Center for Internet and
Society at Harvard. Welcome, Dr. Mickens.
Christina Couch: Dr. Mareena Robinson Snowden
is one of MIT's own. She is a senior engineer
at the National Security.
Christina Couch: Analysis Department at the
Johns Hopkins University Applied Physics Laboratory.
Prior to her current role, Dr. Snowden completed
fellowships at the National Nuclear Security
Administration
Christina Couch: and the Carnegie Endowment
for International Peace Nuclear Policy Program.
She was the first Black woman to earn a Ph.D.
in nuclear engineering from MIT. Welcome,
Dr. Snowden.
Christina Couch: And our moderator tonight
is actually somebody I was lucky enough to
meet at a communi, excuse me, Communications
Forum event a few years ago.
Christina Couch: We were thrilled that she
agreed to come back.
Christina Couch: Her name is Tanya Ballard
Brown. She is an editor at National Public
Radio where she's worked on stories about
families of shooting victims in New Orleans,
Christina Couch: the aftermath of the Pulse
nightclub shooting, and sexual assault against
people with disabilities. She was a 2019 Nieman
Foundation for Journalism Fellow where she
studied the intersection of humor, satire,
and journalism.
Projects she's edited at NPR and The Washington
Post have been awarded Peabody, Murrow, and
Gracie
awards, among others. Thank you so much to
all of our speakers. I'm going to pass it
off to Tanya right now.
Tanya Ballard Brown: Thanks everybody for
taking time out to come and join us for this
conversation
Tanya Ballard Brown: this evening. So earlier
this year as people were protesting in the
streets and demanding an
Tanya Ballard Brown: end to racial injustice
and calling for solutions to ending systemic
racism, that energy spread
beyond just policing and beyond the Black
Lives Matter slate of policy proposals
and into other areas, such as my industry,
media, but also into academia. And over the
summer
that hashtag Black in the Ivory started trending
and it gained traction as Black scholars like
all these
wonderful, really accomplished people that
we have here today, shared their experiences
confronting
and contending with discrimination and alienation
and other issues in colleges and universities.
Tanya Ballard Brown: And so today we want
to talk about some of what was shared in the
tweet thread and what
continues to be shared, as well as best practices,
lessons learned, and how to navigate some
of these
situations that others have been struggling
with over the years. And so I want to throw
this first
to Shardé -- I'm going to call people by
their first names. I'm Tanya, too. I'm Tanya
-- who was the
main engine behind the hashtag. And just to
give us, just talk to us a little bit about
why
you did this, and what were some of the stories
that were shared. What trends or
recurring themes did you see shared when you
started this conversation and got this conversation
going.
Shardé Davis: Absolutely. Hi, everyone. Good
evening. I'm really humbled to be in this
space
Shardé Davis: with so many brilliant minds
and to able to talk about this really pertinent
topic.
Shardé Davis: One that we know has always
been around, anti-Black racism in the academy.
We also
Shardé Davis: know anti-Black racism is built
into the bedrock of the United States. So
naturally, it is going to
manifest itself in various social institutions.
And I think that's, not I think, but that
really is the kind of starting point to how.
I started to think about this because I was
just reeling
in over the summer, quarantining because of
Covid, And, you know, kind of sitting in what
felt like isolation in a rental apartment
in California and out protesting, just feeling
like
Shardé Davis: I was trying to do something,
right? I was trying to somehow make sense
of who I am as a Black woman
and how my, this kind of capital C conversation
that was happening this summer, this racial
reckoning, how that showed up in my own life.
And because I thankfully, knock on wood, had
not had
Shardé Davis: personal run-ins with the police
when it comes to mass incarceration, when
it comes to police
brutality, it doesn't mean that anti-Black
racism doesn't manifest in my life. And so
I was
just sitting there thinking about, what does
this mean to me, right? And how does this
show up within my
own immediate sphere of influence, and immediately
just started thinking about the academy and
my own
experiences, and just an interesting play
on words, right? Seemingly so simple, right?
Being Black in the Ivory for me felt like
a speck in a sea of white, which, growing
up in San Diego, going
to predominantly white institutions all of
my life in terms of secondary education, that's
just the
recurring theme and I just remember that Sunday
when it was trending. And I think it was in
the
Shardé Davis: top 20 hashtags across the
United States that Sunday. I mean, I was just
floored that, you know, for
me, it just started, I just was using that
as a way to process what was happening around
me.
Shardé Davis: And it's crazy how it, it's
crazy but it's not how it resonated with so
many other Blackademics, right?
Shardé Davis: And in reading the tweets and,
I mean talk about all your plans being cancelled
that day,
because I was just reading. I just couldn't
stop. I wanted to make sure I was reading
every
single tweet and in terms of the stories that
were surfacing, I don't know. I think about
this phrase,
I've used this recently, the death by 1,000
paper cuts. So absolutely, that does not mean
that
many Blackademics around the globe have not
experienced overt racism. Some women had talked
about sexual assault, right, so thinking about
intersectionality and how we cannot untether
our racial identity from our gender identity
and other identities as well, sexuality and
age.
Shardé Davis: But it was the micro aggressions,
the unwanted touches to someone's hair for
specifically
those who were donning their natural kind
of kinky curls and other natural hairstyles,
Shardé Davis: being questioned about if they're
the janitor. You know what I mean, when
they're in a lab after hours, being asked
for identification when they're trying to
go into the
lecture hall to teach by campus police right.
So you know these incidences where again,
you know,
racial micro-aggressions is the psychological
warfare, where you're questioning is it me?
Shardé Davis: This seems racially motivated,
but I can't, I can't tell. I can't quite put
my finger on it. So it was in,
I'll just say this and just to kind of wrap
up my answer to your question, but what I
found
to be the most interesting, one of the most
interesting pieces in reading the tweets was
how sometimes people were sharing the exact
same story. And I mean, down to the minutia.
Shardé Davis: And these are people who are
went to grad school at different time periods,
who
Shardé Davis: are different generations in
terms of like age groups, people who, men
and women, different fields,
Shardé Davis: they're from programs across
the United States and saying the exact same
story.
Tanya Ballard Brown: Well, thank you. I think
it is interesting that you had, you found
that there was so much,
Tanya Ballard Brown: but repetition in the
stories that people were telling and that
segues a little
Tanya Ballard Brown: bit into, I want to throw
this question to James, Dr. Mickens
Tanya Ballard Brown: Sociologist Tsedale M.
Melaku has described the inclusion tax, right.
She's talked about the time spent,
Tanya Ballard Brown: the money spent, the
emotions spent, the brainpower spent trying
to adhere to norms in
Tanya Ballard Brown: academic spaces, and
I'm curious, and you've talked about this
a little yourself in
Tanya Ballard Brown: other areas, but I'm
curious what ways you've found to push back
against some of that in your career.
James Mickens: Thanks for the question and
I'm glad to be here, glad to see so many people
on the call. I think
James Mickens: that that question that you
asked, I mean it's a hard one to answer because,
in a certain sense,
James Mickens: it speaks to the fact that
there is this additional burden that scholars
of color oftentimes have to
James Mickens: face in addition to the other
things that scholars already do that makes
scholarship hard, you know,
publish or perish, being on committees, you
know, all this type of stuff. And so it's
difficult. You know,
I think that one reason why it's difficult
is because it can be hard to tell someone,
look I know that you're busy, but I'm actually
probably a little bit busier than you
because of the various committees, for example,
that I'm asked to
be on that you might not be asked to be on,
not because you're a bad person. Just because,
you know, people are looking for the diversity
unit,
you know. And so I think that one of the things
that I try to coach young academics on,
that I try to be very intentional about my
own career is being able to, to be frank and
to be polite.
James Mickens: But to be open about the fact
that there are certain things that I want
to do
because I want to increase, for example, diversity
in professoriate. There are certain things
I'm
asked to do that perhaps I don't necessarily
want to do, but I feel like I should do as
a service.
James Mickens: But then that means that there
are some things I simply won't have time to
do.
And I think that it's, it's sort of like more
of an art than a science when you need to
convey
these messages, when you need to tell someone
who might be, for example, your chair or your
dean or
someone like this, your direct manager if
you're an industry, that I would love to do
this but, you know,
ellipses, I'm doing these other things. And
so one thing that I found very helpful is
that first of all, when you're having one
of these conversations, you need to figure
out, am
I dealing with someone who's reasonable or
not? I mean, just to put it bluntly, is this
a person
who you can actually negotiate with, who you
can sort of trust to sort of be sympathetic
with you
James Mickens: even if they don't immediately
understand what your current burdens are?
Because if the answer is
no, if it's not a reasonable person, that's
like a whole other sort of, you know, path
and decision
tree as engineers might say. But if it's someone
who is reasonable, then oftentimes I find
it very
effective and actually very educational for
both people to say, "Here's what my current
state of
things looks like. I'm on this many committees.
I'm, you know, mentoring this many students.
You know,
this is my teaching load. This is what I'm
doing with respect to research. So here's
what I think
my priorities are. What do you think my priorities
should be?" And, you know, if you phrase that
in sort
of a polite way, but in sort of an honest
way and a direct way, I think that can actually
sort of recalibrate how people think sometimes
about what the burden of a scholar of color
is.
James Mickens: Because I think there's a large
set of people in academia who are well intentioned,
but ignorant.
And just to be clear, that includes me, that
includes everyone. We're all sort of ignorant
about something. But I think there's a large
set of people in academia, who, they're not
in the Klan.
They're not, you know, quote unquote "obvious
racists." They're not burning crosses in people's
front yard
and yet, you know, they're actually without
knowing it, complicit is too strong of a word,
but
they don't understand that, you know, we're
all embedded in sort of this larger social
structure
and we all play a certain role in making sure
that certain things that have inertia either
continue or don't continue. So I've actually
found that very useful to say, "This is what
my next year
looks like. So, you know, you're asking me
to do this. Do you think that, you know, how
do you think this
fits into my overall plan? Do you think I
should maybe drop something else?" You know,
sometimes they
say yes. Sometimes they'll say, yeah, I think
you should actually you know do this instead
of that,
and that's good feedback for you to hear,
perhaps as well. But I think that one of the
big
challenges I see for scholars of color is
that they try to say yes to everything,
James Mickens: in part because of a fear of
being sort of stereotyped as sort of the the
angry person of color
or, you know, this is someone, you know, "Well,
when I asked Steve to do this, Steve didn't
complain about this,"
you know. So I think there is a fine line
there, but I think that in general, in life,
it's
very helpful to be intentional about the things
that you do. You know when you want to get
some
professional or personal goal, think explicitly
about what steps you're going to take to get
there.
James Mickens: And I think this sort of advice
to be intentional is doubly important in academia,
in part because there's so many people who
can ask you what to do, right, and try to
suggest
that you do certain things. You know, I used
to spend some time in industry and that's
one
of the biggest differences I found between
industry and academia. In industry, I nominally
have one boss,
you know? In academia, anyone can send me
an email. You know, students can send me an
email, people,
other professors can send me an email. So
it's really important to be intentional about
how you choose what you do.
Tanya Ballard Brown: I want to throw that
same question to Dr. Snowden. Mareena, in
terms of how you have
Tanya Ballard Brown: learned to manage some
of those expectations, some of that additional
work, that laborious work
Tanya Ballard Brown: that maybe someone not
of color is not having to take on
Mareena Robinson Snowden: Yeah, you know,
it's really, I think that James and Shardé
really just hit the nail on the head with
Mareena Robinson Snowden: so many pieces of
their answer, right. So, so, you know, James
was talking about
Mareena Robinson Snowden: this honesty and
transparency right and owning the fact that
your time, you know, time is the most
limited resource, right, and oftentimes we
struggle with saying no, right. That is what
James is saying,
you need to be able to say no. To be intentional
is to have to prioritize, right, and one of
the hardest
things, I think, scholars and practitioners
of color have to deal with is prioritizing
ourselves
because the environment seems so unstable
for us, right. Because you are often the only
one in
the room, so every decision that you make
feels so consequential. Even in reality, it
may or may not be, right?
We recognizes and acknowledge that there is
perception and then there's also
reality on both sides of the equation. Right.
Um, but I think this, this, this skill and
ability, which
is something that is built, right, to be able
to prioritize yourself and your career and
say no
is key. Right. Now it's interesting because,
for me, you know, I was steeped and raised
in the tradition
of Historically Black Colleges and Universities.
Right. And so much of that, I'm a proud graduate
of Florida A&M University. So before I had
anything to do with MIT, I was a rattler,
okay and the rattler perspective.
Tanya Ballard Brown: I'm North Carolina A&T
Mareena Robinson Snowden: Come on now, Come
on now. Okay. But that, that HBCU perspective
is about, to a degree selflessness. Right.
It's about putting yourself in a position
to help your culture, right.
So there is a balance that has to be struck
between being so laser focused on your own
success
and because it is a testament and a data pointfor
your culture about what can happen, and then
kind of what I feel as a duty to the culture
to contribute to this work, right.
So, the committee work that James and Shardé
talked about, right. Like there, for me,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: it's not, I never
feel comfortable because of that sense of
duty saying no to everything, right.
Like you have to make space for that. And
I think that's, you know, I think James
and Shardé would agree. You know, Shardé
talked about this, this question of is it
me, right?
Like they asked, they stopping me? Like am
I tripping? Like, did I take that the wrong
way? When the guy,
I was at a holiday party in graduate school
and one of the other graduate students walked
up to
me and just, in a very well intentioned way
right James, walked up to me and say, you
know, I'm just,
you know, I know, I used to live near the
inner city and I'm so proud that you were
able to make
it out of the inner city. Right. And I'm sitting
at the holiday party with my little cup of
food
or to plate of food thinking do I respond
to this? Now, what do I say to that, right?
Because
there's so many assumptions built into that
right. Because I am a Black person in this
room, I must
have either been the affirmative action hire
or admit, or I've traversed, you know, crack
needles and all kinds of things to get here,
right. And there are people who live, you
know, our,
our community is so diverse, right. We have
so many different stories, from cultural,
right, like we have
Jamaicans, we have Haitians, we have people
from the African continent, we have people
from Canada,
like Black people are very diverse and broad
right and and to have to come up against
Mareena Robinson Snowden: the assumptions
can be challenging. For me, it was, it was
critical while I was at MIT and now
that I'm at Johns Hopkins to find community
right, because community is the antidote to
gaslighting.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: So when you have
a community of folks that you can go back
to and say, "So this thing happened
to me. Am I trippin?" They can say, "No, you're
not tripping," right. And Shardé's hashtag
was that
in the digital space, right. She created community
in the digital space so people could acknowledge
and corroborate and endorse, right, your experience
and say, "No, you are not crazy. This does
happen
and this is wrong and it exists" to James's
point in this kind of systematic context that
matters,
right. So, you know, James is exactly right.
It is a hard question. But I think you know
community.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: is essential and
learning how to be transparent, not, not necessarily
vulnerable. Okay, but how to be
honest with your abilities at that moment,
and your priorities at that moment is key
to kind of staying along the path.
Tanya Ballard Brown: You say community, are
you like, are you telling people to
Tanya Ballard Brown: seek out people like
yourself instructors who can sort of guide
them to other people or,
Tanya Ballard Brown: or are there resources
that should be your university should be compiling
and making available?
Tanya Ballard Brown: Like, what kind, what,
what kinds of ways do people create these
communities?
Mareena Robinson Snowden: Yeah. So the easy
answer is all of the above. Right. Um, what
I was thinking about was, for me,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: the most transformative
and kind of fortifying force while I was at
MIT and now were my peers,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: right, were my homegirls
and my homeboys who I could, you know, W.E.B.
Du Bois talks about the
mask right. And you could drop the mask and
just be yourself and speak in your language
and
Mareena Robinson Snowden: you know, admit
things that you would never admit in the mainstream
conversation because of that fear of
vulnerability and that stereotype threat,
right, that, that you feel like if you admit
this,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: it's a damnation
on your culture. So I think it's peer community,
but you bring up a very key point.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: The best at, one
of the best pieces of advice that I got when
I was coming up at MIT was,
you have to get people to buy into your success.
So there are people in power in these institutions,
right, whether they're in the provost's office,
whether they're in the dean's office, right,
and they need to know that you exist and you
ain't playing. Right, like you serious business.
You good
at your job, so when the inevitable foolishness
starts because it always gonna be some foolishness,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: you already have
the reputation that no, no, no it's not her
or it's not him. Something else is
up here because I know this person is a serious
scholar and the quality of their work and
the type
of their character, right, so they can start
to question their own system like something's
wrong here. If she's having trouble and she's
a stellar student or scholar or professor,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: we must be dropping
the ball somewhere, right, so it's communities
at all levels, Tanya.
Tanya Ballard Brown: This brings me back to
Shardé because earlier this year in an interview,
you talked about
Tanya Ballard Brown: how white academics have
not given weight or attention to systemic
racism. And so my question
Tanya Ballard Brown: sort of also it builds
on what Mareena was just saying is with, you
know, white faculty and
staff making up like 70% of campuses nationwide,
what do you see is their role in helping to
Tanya Ballard Brown: dismantle systemic racism?
Do you, that's a hard question. This is for
Shardé though.
Shardé Davis: Right. [laughs] Yeah
Tanya Ballard Brown: What would you have them
do?
Shardé Davis: They have a lot to do. They
have a lot to do. Can I have to just say Mareena's
preaching. Okay. She
Shardé Davis: took this from like a webinar,
a forum to some kitchen table talk. I'm here
for everything
Shardé Davis: that she that, she said and
if I can lean into my research in terms of
the communities
Shardé Davis: and peers and the necessity
of having, for Black women, for example, a
sister circle, right.
Shardé Davis: Thinking about the identities
that you hold right and where you sit and
your vantage point and finding
other individuals who are situated similarly
to you. And that can also mean other, for
example, other
Blackademics and creating a community. They
don't even necessarily have to be Blackademics
at your institution but even other Blackacademics
nationwide, right, because they understand
what it
means to be one of the only right in in that
space, but also thinking about, sometimes
you just need
to lean on your sister girls. Right and even
though they might not necessarily be academics
or affiliated with the university, there is
a shared understanding about our
double jeopardy, right, being both Black and
women. And ways in which they might be confronting
gendered racism within their own sphere of
influence, within their own job that might
overlap or read
similarly to what we experience so, yeah,
I just, I just had to just kind of cosign
with what she was
what she was preaching on. Um, white folks,
white academics, what, what is it that they
can
do? There's a lot that they can do. One, I've
been thinking about this a lot and I really
think
some of them need to have an introspective
moment about
Shardé Davis: about their own, the seeds
that have been planted by their parents, by
other socializing
Shardé Davis: agents, by their grandparents,
right. I mean, many of us are only one to
two generations away
Shardé Davis: from, you know, white communities,
other communities of color who have been spewing
anti-Black rhetoric and and have been very
unabashed, in doing so, right. So,
Shardé Davis: it’s, to think that, you
know, someone's aunt, someone's grandparents
or great grandparents who were
a part of those communities, who are part
of perpetuating that rhetoric, to think that
they have no influence on you, right is, that’s
foolish. So I think white individuals need
to have an
introspective moment about what has been planted
inside of them, what beliefs, albeit some
maybe
deep seated right that are, that are, that
are situated, perhaps even in their subconscious,
and really interrogating that. Many people
are, you know, we talked about therapy, this
is also another
Shardé Davis: topic that we should be, white
folks especially should be talking about in
therapy right.
Shardé Davis: How they might be complicit
or how they might be, again, perpetuating
this in just their everyday walks of life.
Shardé Davis: I also think white folks need
to think about not only what their work life
looks
like, but oftentimes what you do at work is
a reflection of your own personal life.
How many, look at your own friendship network.
Do you only hang around white folks?
Shardé Davis: Think about the books that
you read. Is it mainly white authors? Think
about
the restaurants that you patron. Are they
mainly owned by white people? Is it only serving
kind of
standard American food? Think about the, the,
the, your leisure activities, your gym
Shardé Davis: or other classes that you take,
fitness classes that you take, thinking about
different kinds of
seminars or workshops in your community that
you attend. Who else is in the room? Who's
teaching it?
What are they talking about? That's a reflection
of you and your beliefs, your desires, your
ideas right.
Again, sometimes it's subconscious. We're
subconsciously making these decisions, but
what
we believe is going to guide how we behave.
So I think that, you know, there needs to
be, again,
an introspective moment about where someone
is situated personally in their own personal
life.
Shardé Davis: Um, and I don't want to say
before, but that definitely needs to be working
in tandem with
the work that they're doing at the university.
I also think that white academics absolutely
Shardé Davis: need to, well I don't want
to say stop, but to stop offloading this work
on to blackademics
and even on to other people of color. We all
have a role. That could mean making a concerted
effort to
Shardé Davis: to mentor and advise other
Black graduate students. That is not just
the responsibility
of Black faculty to advise and / or mentor
Black graduate students and Black undergraduate
students,
absolutely not. They have a role in that as
well. That could mean sacrificing their privilege,
de-centering their privilege
and sacrificing, I shouldn't say sacrificing,
but sacrificing their,
Shardé Davis: their I guess comfort. Right.
But I mean, white folks benefit from privilege
and that then allows them
to move up and matriculate the ladder, to
maneuver the university in a way that's much
easier.
Shardé Davis: than their Black counterparts.
So there's a way in which they need to sacrifice
that. There's a way in which
they need to sacrifice that comfort to create
room so that we can start, start to maneuver,
so that some of
our needs and desires can now be centered.
Um, there's a way in which they need to, if
they find
themselves in, I was talking about this with
some faculty of color who I work with
at UConn and how there are some open positions
for admin in the administrative
kind of realm or tier of our university. If
white folks find themselves getting tapped
on the
shoulder, perhaps they need to think about
some of their Black peers or their Black colleagues
who are also more than qualified even to be
in that position, and perhaps not go and to
take
that and to go and suggest someone else's
name, put someone else's name in the ring,
right.
Shardé Davis: Um, there are even just small
micro behaviors that folks can do. I learned
this theory
called shine theory, which is when in meetings,
for example, if you hear me say an idea and
Shardé Davis: to go and to repeat that idea
because 9 times out of 10, no one's going
to either hear it
Shardé Davis: or they're not going to give
me the acknowledgement. They're going to maybe
like the idea, but not
going to attach it to myself and they're going
to go and then take the, basically co-op the
idea, right.
So with shine theory, it’s saying that people
in positions of power,
to repeat it and to cite it so that not only
the idea gets goes forth, but also the individual
who
owns it. Right. They then are tethered to
it. So even something as simple as
making sure that we're not getting erased
and that we are getting our proper dues. Gosh,
I mean, there's just, I could go on and on.
I'm sure we all could kind of collate all
these various things that they could do in
their personal life and their professional
life. Right. And I think you got to do the
research, say it again.
Tanya Ballard Brown: I want to give James
and Mareena a chance to to share some ideas
about what they, what changes
Tanya Ballard Brown: they think that white
faculty members and other academics might
be able to do to help
Tanya Ballard Brown: dismantle some of the
systemic racism.
James Mickens: Well, I think, as always, you
know, your track record of asking difficult
questions continues.
James Mickens: I appreciate that you're keeping
us on our feet. What I think is sort of underlying
James Mickens: That's right. We wanted the
best, we got the best. I think that one of
the things which is sort
James Mickens: of underlying your question,
which I think is interesting, and I'll just
put it out there bluntly.
I think one of the big challenges in academia
is what do with the case of the white
progressive who voted for Obama? Right, there's
like a great scene in Get Out that sort of
addresses
this very thing. You know, like, you'll find
these people in academia, who, you know, they
want
to believe they vote the right way. You know,
like, oh yeah, I voted for Obama. I totally
believe in
policies X, Y, and Z. But so to get into something
that Shardé was saying, it's like, but are
you
living a life, you know, sort of academically,
in sort of personally, that reflect how you
think
that you're voting preferences is sort of,
you know, making claims on on on the world.
So, for example, like, and this is something,
as I mentioned, my some of the other panelists.
James Mickens: Not just women and people of
color can be on diversity committees. It's
possible that, you know,
white men can be on those committees. When
you're looking at, you know, how are we going
to manage
James Mickens: You know, a daycare for for
professors who have children, it doesn't just
have to be women
on that committee. When we're looking at,
to Mareena’s point, looking at, well, how
can
we increase the diversity of our graduate
student admins,
it doesn't just have to be people who have
the demographic characteristics that you want
to improve being on that committee.
And so I think that
it's important, and once again, this is another
one of those difficult conversations that
you,
you have to sort of midwife with some grace
and with some, some charm. But I think it's
important
to ask people to basically step up to these
things to say, you know, can you act as an
ally,
because I think, in many cases, that's really
what's lacking in in academia. Not just people
who say, like, “Yes, I believe in X, Y,
and Z,” but it's like will you actually
perform explicit
acts of allyship? You know, if you see, for
example, that, you know, a lot of committee
work is being
pushed towards people of color, will you be
an ally and suggest maybe I'll do some of
that
work, or I'll suggest someone else who is
under-burdened who should maybe get some of
that work?
James Mickens: And there are very simple,
very practical things that I think that,
James Mickens: you know, allies can do. So,
for example, when you're thinking about colloquium
speakers.
James Mickens: Who should we invite to come
talk to our students as exemplars of what
academia should look like?
James Mickens: You know, a very simple question
that you can ask in a meeting is, have we
consider people of color here?
Is there anyone that we're missing? Are there
any women that we're missing here? You know,
there's anyone
with a disability, things like this? And what's
interesting is that when you ask that question,
James Mickens: just asking the question, a
lot of people will say, oh, right, right,
why don't we invite
so and so? And so was just that sort of gentle
prodding that was necessary, but someone has
to
do it. You know, someone has to do it, and
you have to sort of set this culture of people
being willing
to ask those questions. And you know, I also
want to really sort of emphasize something
that Mareena
said, which has already been emphasized by
Shardé, but particularly if we have a lot
of engineers in
the audience. Even in engineering, it is a
social science. There are plenty of people
who are super
smart super bright who didn't build the right
network and you don't hear about those folks.
And so I think it's very important, you know,
to build that community and it can't just
be, you know,
people of color in the answer. And, you know,
why is that? Because there's not a lot of
us out there
right now. And so, you know, if you're just
going to hitch your wagon to just a colored
star, your wagon might
not be going very far at a lot of universities,
you know. So I think that if you do have allies,
you
know, who are white, you should you should
allow them to help you because these people
do exist out
there, you know, but I do want to r- emphasize
that point once again that community is so
important.
James Mickens: Because, you know, when you
think about, you know, who gets academic jobs,
academia is very small,
you know, and as I always tell my students
there's sort of like the long line and the
short line, just
like get into a club. You know, you always
want to be in that short line. Right. And
so how do you get
on that short line? You get on the short line
by knowing people and by your allies knowing
people.
And so you want to be very intentional regardless
of what stage of your career you’re at.
You could be a grad student. You could be
a professor. You can be emeritus. It doesn't
matter. You can be retired, right, there's
still things in your life that you want, and
you want to
be intentional about building the community
that will allow you to achieve those goals.
Tanya Ballard Brown: I’ll toss this to Mareena,
but what you talked about this a little bit
about the
Tanya Ballard Brown: culture that BIPOC students
encounter when they're coming to universities
and they're
Tanya Ballard Brown: not necessarily ready
for the campus culture, and just sort of navigating
Tanya Ballard Brown: some of these things.
What responsibility do institutions have to
try to help students,
Tanya Ballard Brown: not just get to the school,
but get through the school and all of these
things that you're talking about?
Tanya Ballard Brown: And what are some of
the things that they might be thinking about
instituting
Tanya Ballard Brown: to help better help students
matriculating, graduate, and be successful
because our numbers
Tanya Ballard Brown: show that we some we
can get there sometimes, but we don't always
get finished. We don’t always cross the
finish line.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: Absolutely. You
know, I think, to your question, what, what
proportion of the responsibility, I say,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: the vast majority
of the responsibility falls on the institution.
Right. And the first thing
Mareena Robinson Snowden: the institution
needs to do is know thyself. Right, like one
of the biggest errors I see consistently
Mareena Robinson Snowden: even now in the
30 years of diversity and equity and inclusion
being mainstream right, like this is
Mareena Robinson Snowden: not a new conversation
we’re having, and that's why this is so
frustrating, right, because this work,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: you know, was instigated
in like really hardcore in the 90s, and it
was the same situation right.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: And the problem
is that institutions, you know, it's very
easy. I see that there's a lot of different
kind of facets to DEI work, right, and, you
know, one of the trends. I see is that institutions
of higher education, industry, military, regardless,
government. Everyone is very comfortable with
the recruitment
conversation, right. How do we get these shining
stars into our institution and once they
get through the door, it’s going to be kumbaya
cause it’s okay, right. Unfortunately, as
you
said, Tanya the data does not bear that out,
right. Students are getting here with all
of the vigor
and enthusiasm and promise, and for whatever
reason they're leaving with a masters when
they applied
for a Ph.D. They're leaving before the tenure
track happens or they're not getting tenure
at all.
Right. And what I find is a consistent error
is that institutions are not tracking this
and if they are tracking it, they're not tracking
it in an actionable way. They're not setting
any
strategies around these numbers, right. I
think the most guarded data in higher ed institutions
is your demographic data and it's guarded
because people are embarrassed, because the
numbers are not
moving in the right direction and they don't
want to be shamed. Right. But we have to move
out of this
frame of embarrassment and shame and just
acknowledge as a collective community under
the context of the legacy of slavery and Jim
Crow and the transatlantic slave trade, right,
like nobody is doing this right. So you're
not uniquely failing in this. We need to get
beyond
the shame, so that we can share, right, and
we can we can strategize together about how
to correct these
trends specifically with respect to cultural
and ethnic diversity, right. Because another
thing
that institutions of higher education are
very comfortable with is defining diversity
in
terms of gender. Right. We are very quick
to talk about how we have achieved at our
beloved MIT,
achieved gender parity in the undergraduate
ranks right. We are near 50/50. The proportion
of
women in STEM is rising, year after year.
But as those same people, how many black folks
they have
in their programs? And what the 10-year trends
look like? They're stagnant, if not reducing
ight, so we have to hold ourselves accountable
to the way that we're defining these terms,
right.
You're defining them in a way that suits you,
in a way that you're proud to talk about their
data,
but if you're not willing to know thyself
and look at yourself, then where are we? We
lost before
we even started. You know, um, I think I,
you know, I just, James, you are the MVP talking
about this
white progressive, my brother. Okay. Because
I read something recently that said, it really
ties in
so well with, it was a Harvard Business Review
article or something and they were talking
about
kind of the other side of, the the other side
of the negative diversity corner where you
have folks that say, “Listen, we have Asian-Americans.
You know, we have a transgender person,
a lesbian person, a gay person. We have a,
you know, a differently abled person.
Like aren't really diverse enough? Like we
did it. We're here.” But, but the question
is, where, where are the,
where's the Black person? Like you ain't done
until you have Black people. And the reason
why
you're not done until you have Black people
there is because you have to frame it in terms
of impact
Mareena Robinson Snowden: right. Diversity
and inclusion work is about who is the most
marginalized? Who is impacted? It's not
about your intention. I understand what you
meant to say, right, but that's not what's
important here.
It's about how your actions land on communities.
Right. And the most effective, still to this
day,
Covid is bearing it out, day after day, right,
if the Black community. From the founding
of this country we have been at the bottom
of the Totem pole. Okay, it's the way it was
set up.
So until you have that group well represented
within your organization, you ain't done.
You can have as many as you want in terms
of your diversity checkboxes. But then, you
know,
so it’s, it's a, it's a very nuanced conversation,
but we have to bring these conversations in
an institutional way, right, and it can't
just be because another Black man got murdered
on camera
that now we're having the Forum. Right. Where
is your diversity officer, department head?
Provost, right?
MIT just released the fact that they want
every department now, to have a dedicated
diversity
officer. That’s, you’re late. This should
have been happening. We were talking about
this when I was
there and I've been gone five years now. Right.
So we need to invest in these positions so
that
it's not only on the students and faculty
of color to be the engines of this work right.
You need to
institutionalize this with positions. When
your dean of diversity and inclusion leaves,
fill
that position. Right, because if it doesn't
get filled, we see where your priorities are
and I'm
looking at you, my institution. Fill the position
so that we can see this work continued to
go,
year after year. But, you know, you asked,
what should faculty and the institutions do?
These are those
things. Know your data. Institutionalize these
roles so somebody can own this progress. Have
a strategic
plan. The same way you have a strategic plan
around building your endowment, and you've
been able to
build billion-dollar endowments, right, because
you have networks and connections and you
set goals
and you track those goals, based on year after
year data, do the same
thing with diversity. Do the same thing with
communities of color, and then we will start
to see the returns on the investment because
right now we've done 30 years of investment
and have nothing to show for it with respect
to Black people. Thank you.
Tanya Ballard Brown: Do y’all think that
Title IX reporting and training are mandatory?
Tanya Ballard Brown: Because this again, you
just said this, but I'm going to ask you,
is mandatory at most
Tanya Ballard Brown: campuses, so do you see
that the the need for the same kind of codification
for diversity, equity, and
Tanya Ballard Brown: inclusion training? Is
that how we get to someone responsible for
the numbers
Tanya Ballard Brown: away from the shame that
you talked about and more accountability and
more action?
Tanya Ballard Brown: Shardé. I’ll throw
it to Shardé.
Shardé Davis: [laughs] I don't think it,
I don't think it hurts. I can put it that
way. Um, I don't think it hurts, as Mareena
said, to have dedicated, I see that as dedicated
Shardé Davis: institutional resourcing right
to addressing racism as it, as it exists across
the,
Shardé Davis: the university. Certainly,
there needs to be some system in place, right,
where individuals who
Shardé Davis: encounter these issues and
who are assaulted can go to the university
and there is a process
Shardé Davis: right by which it will get
addressed and evaluated and handled accordingly
in a way
Shardé Davis: where the person feels as though
the university has responded as they should.
Um, yeah. So that
Shardé Davis: could be an officer. I've yet
to see something like that. I don't know if
this exists at
Shardé Davis: other universities, but I'm
certainly open to the possibilities of imagining
that.
Tanya Ballard Brown: I think we're going to
shift over to taking questions from the audience
now
Tanya Ballard Brown: and Christina gave some
directions, but I'll be quiet and let her
tell you again, just
Tanya Ballard Brown: in case anybody missed
how to submit questions.
Christina Couch: We've got some great questions
already. If you have additional questions,
put them in the Q and A a box below. We're
going to try and get through
Christina Couch: as many as possible. I'll
just read them out and we'll pass them on
to speakers and kind of go from there.
Christina Couch: The first question I'm going
to start out with is non-Black POC exist in
a space between
Christina Couch: whiteness and Blackness and
often, it can be difficult to understand your
role in
Christina Couch: helping dismantle anti-Black
racism in the academy. Do you think there's
any distinct
Christina Couch: or particular role that non-Black
POC should play in the struggle for justice
in academia?
Mareena Robinson Snowden: Does anybody want
to jump in? I'll just throw out a thought
out there real quick. So I think,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: you know, it's a
wonderful question. And to me, it brings up
the idea of coalition building. Right. So,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: James talked about
the fact that unfortunately, the situation
right now is, is that there is so few of
Mareena Robinson Snowden: us, right, and year
to year to year, the numbers even fluctuate
in that small number, right. So you might
Mareena Robinson Snowden: have one or two
or six and then you're really celebrating
right? So in order for us to make an
Mareena Robinson Snowden: impact, there has
to be coalitions forming between all of the
cultural and racial groups in terms
Mareena Robinson Snowden: of the minority
category right. Like the Asian Pacific Islanders
need to link up with the Black
Mareena Robinson Snowden: folks need to link
up with the BGSA to link up with the Hispanic
professional engineers
Mareena Robinson Snowden: right like because
that's the only way that we can have that
kind of, that kind of power
Mareena Robinson Snowden: work in terms of
numbers. What is wonderful about the situation
in terms of the coalition is
a lot of our needs are similar. Right, a lot
of the things that we're going through in
terms of
what we're facing with respect to this within
academia. Maybe our origin stories are a little
bit
different, Right, but the, the systems that
were coming up against an academia, oftentimes
treat
us very similar, right. Now it's now there
are nuances, right, when we talk about, particularly
with respect to in engineering, the presence
of Asian-Americans versus other minority groups,
like there are nuances. I get that. But the
idea of getting together and amplifying each
other's needs,
amplifying each other's demands right and,
and to Shardé's point about Shine Theory,
right, like, shine.
Like if the Hispanic student group or the
Hispanic faculty something, like all
the minority clubs and, and, and affinity
groups need to link up behind because that
sends a demand signal
to leadership. Right. Because also another
thing we have to acknowledge in this space
right now
is we have power. Okay. They don't want to
lose us. They ain't got but three of us.
Okay, so if we all band together, right, and
make our demands very, very clear, you know
that sends a signal to them to listen. You
better listen before all before your diversity
walk out the
door and go to the next university. Because
we are in demand and it's it's not something
that
we have to shy away from. It's nothing that
we created. Okay, but we can leverage that
power that we have right now until the system
has changed to try to push the system forward.
Shardé Davis: Yeah. And if I can just say
that we kind of are holding, I guess, intention,
in a way,
Shardé Davis: but this kind of POC coalition
building right and the solidarity that gets
Shardé Davis: invoked, and rightly should
be with moments that are focused on particular
community.
Shardé Davis: Right. And this is a Black
moment. So I, I think for me, we need our
non-Black POCS to recognize
Shardé Davis: that to not try and for administrators,
not to try to do the broad paint stroke of
Shardé Davis: we're going to dedicate these
dollars for all diverse groups or
Shardé Davis: all kind of groups of color.
No. I need dedicated dollars for Black people,
Shardé Davis: Black staff, Black undergraduate
students, graduate students, and faculty.
I need folks to be bold and
Shardé Davis: to lean into that and for our
non-Black POCS to support us in that endeavor.
Shardé Davis: Yeah. We really need to lean
into the nuance, right, and that we have specific
needs as Black folks
Shardé Davis: that are, that need to be focused
on because when we go and try to invoke that
kind of all POC
Shardé Davis: or issues, right, Black people,
we end up losing and we end up going invisible
and unheard.
James Mickens: Yeah. I would also say the
allyship issue is important too, because,
you know, although I think
James Mickens: there should be sort of like
top-down requirements for institutions to
think about these issues
James Mickens: of race and Blackness, in particular,
a lot of times those mandates can seem very
artificial
James Mickens: and therefore easy for people
to ignore if it's not seen as being something
that is
James Mickens: also important organically
for the community. Right. So it's like, you
know, think about like ethics
James Mickens: training if you're a scientist.
Most scientists, I mean, they're like, Yeah,
okay. So don't push people
James Mickens: down the stairs. Try not to
blow up the lab, like, cool. I'm done. Right,
in part because
James Mickens: pro forma. It feels like I
just have to check this box and then be done
with it, you know.
James Mickens: So I think that this is one
reason why allyship with non-Black POCs is
so important because
Jamesmickens: it builds the size of the coalition
and it will make the people in power see that
it is actually
James Mickens: something the community is
experiencing and feels is important as opposed
to, there was this edict
James Mickens: that got passed by, you know,
the president or the provost and I just need
to check that box and I can
James Mickens: keep my job. Instead, it's
like the people who are ostensibly my constituents,
whose, you know,
James Mickens: care has been entrusted to
me, they actually feel this is an important
topic.
Christina Couch: Here's the next question.
Many different diversity, equity, and inclusion
Christina Couch: committees have sprung up
recently students who are Black, indigenous,
or people of color
Christina Couch: disproportionately get asked
to be on these committees. The problem is
that we are typically
Christina Couch: the most active and likely
to be able to make change. It is a burden
to speak up and more of
Christina Couch: a burden to expect to make
the fixes we are pointing out. How do we navigate
this issue?
James Mickens: I'd say, I mean, once again,
another hard question just raining, falling
down from the sky. So
James Mickens: I think that this is one reason
why it's actually important to try to be frank
and
James Mickens: have honest conversations with
the people who are tasking you to do these
things. So, you know,
James Mickens: sometimes when I get invited
to do things, like be on a diversity committee,
for example.
James Mickens: I will sometimes say, and,
you know, I'm tenured now so I'm not worried
about getting fired. But I
James Mickens: will sometimes say something
like, so can you tell me how many other people
be on this committee?
James Mickens: How many of them will be white?
How many of them will be men? How many will
be women? Because it's
James Mickens: important for me to not be
on a committee that’s, you know, let's say
it's about, you know, say Black
James Mickens: inclusion, that it's only Black
people because yes, you clearly want people
at that table when
James Mickens: you have that conversation
to bring their lived experiences, but it can't
just be the burden of,
James Mickens: you know, sort of like the
disenfranchised to sort of enfranchise themselves,
right. It’s the
James Mickens: system, so it takes voices
from all across the spectrum. And so I think
that can be challenging
James Mickens: when you're a student, when
you might not feel that you have as much protection
there. But if you have
James Mickens: allies, for example, either
in numbers amongst other students, or if you
have other faculty members who
James Mickens: you feel comfortable sharing
these ideas with, it's helpful when you have
someone who can
James Mickens: be external to the direct situation
to come in there and vouch for you and the
say, well, there's
James Mickens: something, who does not quite
right. You know, we're already not providing
enough support for
James Mickens: our students of color, and
now we're also asking them to do these extra
things in addition to
James Mickens: pass their quals and write
papers and do lab work and stuff like that.
So I think it's just
James Mickens: really important to get to
a place where you can have those frank conversations
about those things.
Shardé Davis: Something I did recently, my
department started a DEI task force by my
very good friend and
Shardé Davis: colleague and I, it was our
idea, but I told her pretty frankly, speaking
to what James had said,
Shardé Davis: I am not going to be chair.
I have no interest being chair of this committee
and I will be
Shardé Davis: on it, but more so as a way
as a kind of a check and balance because I
fear a whole bunch of white
Shardé Davis: folks on a DEI committee, it
can go real wrong, real fast. Um, but I essentially
kind of worked it
Shardé Davis: out with her in terms of a
strategy where she knew, like please do not
call me to do everything. I’m
Shardé Davis: probably not going to be on
a, on a whole bunch of subcommittees. I have
enough to do. This is the role
Shardé Davis: that I want to play. And in
a way, also, I also made it clear, which is
it's kind of carping
Shardé Davis: to when I was talking about
Shine Theory and the ideas that we have and
how they can get stolen
Shardé Davis: and co-opted, that when she
comes to me, which sometimes she does about
certain things that she
Shardé Davis: wants to do with the committee
and she wants a sounding board, that she makes
sure she gives me credit
Shardé Davis: in the meeting. Because I also
find that when we're sitting on these committees,
people do a lot
Shardé Davis: of the picking of your brain
and right and wanting to go and to kind of
consult with you
Shardé Davis: and then end up taking your
ideas and not giving you any to-do for what,
for what it is that you’re,
Shardé Davis: right, you're contributing
to the group. So I think, again, the honesty
and transparency and
Shardé Davis: also kind of strategy. And
if that’s not necessarily with the entire
group, then making
Shardé Davis: sure that you're having that
conversation with the, the chair or the member
that’s leading it.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: And if I can just
give a quick two-finger on that, you know,
in addition to everything that James
Mareena Robinson Snowden: and Shardé just
said, also, as you’re, whatever level you're
at, the person who asked this question,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: be compassionate
with yourself as you build that muscle of
prioritization and advocacy
Mareena Robinson Snowden: for yourself. Right.
Because we talked about that tax earlier.
And oftentimes, when you have
Mareena Robinson Snowden: so many demands
on your time and things coming in, there can
start to become like almost a
Mareena Robinson Snowden: spectator conversation
going on in your head about how you should
have done this different
Mareena Robinson Snowden: or should have done
that different. Like you have to forgive yourself
if you say yes to one too many
Mareena Robinson Snowden: things right ,and
then use that data to course correct later
right. But you know so much of our
Mareena Robinson Snowden: culture right now
is expecting people to arrive at 100%, like
arrive knowing exactly what to do
Mareena Robinson Snowden: and exactly how
to handle situations and it's just not the
reality of the situation. As you have more
Mareena Robinson Snowden: interactions with
these situations, you get better and better
at saying no, or I would rather do this
Mareena Robinson Snowden: or that, or to Shardé’s
point, strategizing with people and telling
them exactly what you need
Mareena Robinson Snowden: in that moment,
right. So, you know, I wish I would
Mareena Robinson Snowden: have known that
earlier in my career and I would have saved
a lot of mental kind of critique of myself,
understanding that it's a process.
Christina Couch: And the next question is,
thank you so much for this wonderful conversation.
I resonated so much with
Christina Couch: everything said as a Black
engineering Ph.D. student. I'm on one of the
many DEI
Christina Couch: committees in my university
and I'm tired of the lack of self awareness,
especially when
Christina Couch: it comes to understanding
the problems BIPOC students face in academia
and the simultaneous
Christina Couch: lack of willingness to spend
money for DEI assessments and solutions. How
do we demand the
Christina Couch: resources required to make
real institutional change? I'm tired and my
patients is waning.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: So I have a thought.
And I'm not sure if it's a good thought. Okay,
well, I’m going to throw it out
Mareena Robinson Snowden: there. Okay. I remember
being a graduate student and just feeling
the exact same feelings right,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: that salt because
this was before George Floyd right. I was
in graduate school when Trayvon Martin,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: right, Mike Brown,
was happening and it was the same uproar.
A little less white people on the
Mareena Robinson Snowden: protest line. But
nonetheless, the same enthusiasm. And one
of the things that kept coming up for me
Mareena RobinsonSnowden: was, um, that exact
question, right. Like how do I, how do we
not let this just be lip service?
Mareena Robinson Snowden: And I think Shardé
has a wonderful example of this, about how
being a little more public
Mareena Robinson Snowden: with your frustration
or with your experience right. And there's
a way to do this
Mareena Robinson Snowden: right, and, and,
and we have to acknowledge the risk with being
more public, right, writing an article
Mareena Robinson Snowden: about your experience,
sending a tweet about your experience. Like
there is a lot of risk to
Mareena Robinson Snowden: that. So i'm not
minimizing or dismissing that, but I think
there's a role for introducing
Mareena Robinson Snowden: the conversation
in a way that is a little bit further than
the walls of your institution.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: And maybe the way
to approach it if you are in a in a in a more
risky situation which, let's say you're
Mareena Robinson Snowden: a graduate student
and you're trying to get your Ph.D., you don't
have that yet. Right.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: Is to always try
to frame it in the most collaborative terms
possible right. You're
Mraeena Robinson Snowden: trying to bring
the institution along as opposed to convicting
them which the frustration makes
Mareena Robinson Snowden: you feel like you
want to do, right. You want to have a kind
of “how might we” conversation. How might
we
Mareena Robinson Snowden: bring about this?
How might we, right? It's a we thing, but
in a way that brings in stakeholders
Mareena Robinson Snowden: from beyond your
institution in a little bit more public facing
way. And I wonder, because you know, at
Mareena Robinson Snowden: the end of the day,
what we have to acknowledge, for good or for
bad are these institutions are
Mareena Robinson Snowden: brands. Right, they’re
brands and the biggest threat to their brand
is you going public, is you say, is
Mareena Robinson Snowden: you starting Black
in the Ivory. And you best believe Shardé's
Mareena Robinson Snowden: university took
notice. You know, took notice, probably wanted,
Shardé you should speak
Mareena Robinson Snowden: to this. Probably
wanted to talk to you, wanted to get your
ideas and your thoughts. Right. So there's
Mareena Robinson Snowden: there's a way to
balance and to strategize that risk versus
that reward of shining a little
Mareena Robinson Snowden: bit more of a light
on the specific experience that you might
be having in your university.
Shardé Davis: Yes, oh yes risk. Mm hmm. Um,
yeah. And that's a that's an internal conversation
you have to have with
Shardé Davis:yourself about if you can do
it, you know. There is something about yeah
invoking
Shardé Davis: or kind of, I guess, community.
You're building a coalition nationwide or
even global-wide with
Shardé Davis: the other Black graduate students
who likely are experiencing very similar things
Shardé Davis: or even Black graduate students
at your university. Something that comes to
mind at
Shardé Davis: UConn is they started on this
Instagram page called Black at UConn
Shardé Davis: and it's anonymous, but students
can go and post to the page about whatever
it is they're
Shardé Davis: experiencing Black at UConn
and everyone can see the responses, but it's
not attached to an
Shardé Davis: identity. And let me tell you,
that has shaken UConn like nobody's business
and I love it.
Shardé Davis: I love it. I think it's, it
was it's student-created, student ran and
the university doesn't try to, I mean,
Shardé Davis: what can they do? It's on a
third-party social media platform. Um, but
I think it's a really
Shardé Davis: beautiful way of where students
really leaned into the power that they have
to go and to share their
Shardé Davis: kind of grievances, knowing
that the university is taking taking note
of it. And they have. So I
Shardé Davis: think there's certainly absolutely
power in that and yes I have seen a 180. When
I was doing this
Shardé Davis: work before Black in the Ivory
popped off, and I mean literally within a
month, meeting with the president before and
meeting with the
Shardé Davis: president after. Let me tell
you, there was a difference. So
Shardé Davis: sometimes you do have to kind
of, I don't say poke the bear cause that's
not what
Shardé Davis: we’re doing. We’re not
talking about provoking, but it is about being
a bit more forthright and more public
Shardé Davis: with your experiences. And
you're right. It is a brand and they want
to protect that brand.
James Mickens: Yeah, and I would just add
that it is important to think about the
James Mickens: before and the after there.
Because it's one thing to be able to get the
bear’s attention, but now you're
James Mickens: in the bear cave. And so what
do you do?And I think there's certain words
that you want to use. You
want to be very strategic when you talk to
power. Right. So, for example, like one phrase
I always use,
James Mickens: I say “what are concrete
and specific things that we're going to do
to sort of address this issue?”
James Mickens: And the reason why concrete
and specific is important is because you don't
want the powers
James Mickens: that be to issue some very
generic statement that say, Um, we feel super
bad about this. Like clearly
James Mickens: they would gussy it up. Like
there are so many statements that come out.
They just say, “this is a
James Mickens: shame and really something
should be done,” like babushka dolls of
passive voice. So you want to say,
James Mickens: okay, what are the concrete,
specific things that we're going to do here?
And then you also want to
James Mickens: say, what are the evaluation
metrics? So given that you've committed to
these concrete, specific things,
James Mickens: how will we know, and to Mareena’s
point, say we. You know, don't, don't go in
there and it's like
James Mickens: a knife fight, but say how
are we going to figure out whether these concrete,
specific things worked
James Mickens: or not? Because you want to
hold people accountable. And I think it's
really important, for example, like
James Mickens: when you go into meetings,
you know, this is kind of like a Jedi mind
trick, but you know going there
James Mickens: with a sheet of paper, so people
can see how much or how little you've written
down as a result
James Mickens: of what other people have said
to you. You know, because if you come into
the meeting and you ask
James Mickens: the question, like, what are
the concrete, specific things we're going
to do? You take the cap off your
James Mickens: pen. Get your best smile. Yeah,
I’m listening and then you don't write anything
down, that’s a very
James Mickens: sort of subtle but like not
so subtle message that we haven't really made
progress here. We're just
James Mickens: sort of exchanging platitudes.
And I think that, you know, that's one trap
that sometimes I see students
James Mickens: in particular fall into where
they're very sort of energetic. They're very
enthusiastic. But the
James Mickens: thing is, you know, the people
in power, they’re there for a reason. They
know all these techniques
James Mickens: and one of those techniques
is to run the clock out. You know, you’ve
got an hour-long meeting.
James Mickens: You spend 45 minutes of it
on platitudes. The assistant knocks on the
door, 15 more minutes.
James Mickens: You look at your agenda, you’ve
discussed nothing. Right. So whenever you
talk to power you need to
James Mickens: be very clear about trying
to set the agenda and be polite, but have
specific goals that you want
James Mickens: for you in terms of what you
say, specific asks you want to make of them,
and always ask about
James Mickens: that evaluation metric thing
because if you don't have evaluation, then
it's very easy for the powers
James Mickens: that be to sort of semi-commit
to something, but then nothing really gets
done.
Shardé Davis: That’s so good. And in fact,
sometimes, or not sometimes, the group I work
with, we email them
Shardé Davis: the agenda beforehand. Right,
so that they, we all know what it is that
we plan to speak about
Shardé Davis: and if I can add just one more
thing in terms of strategy and doing this
work and the risk is,
Shardé Davis: and you can take this as you
will, but when my voice started to become
a little bit louder
Shardé Davis: and I started to come a little
bit more unabashed in in what I said when
my record got stronger.
Shardé Davis: Take it as you will. And I'm
not saying that this is, you know, necessarily
even advice, but I,
Shardé Davis: when I knew, like 10 years
is never given by any stretch, but when I
knew, like, you know, I, I've
Shardé Davis: hit the publication number
to where, you know what I mean, where like
it’s a lawsuit at this
Shardé Davis: point, I felt a little bit
more comfortable. When I knew that, like,
you know, my teaching is good.
Shardé Davis: My services is, you know, I
blow other people out the water in terms of
what I'm doing at all levels
Shardé Davis: — university, department,
professional, my researchers on point in all
aspects, in top-tier journals,
Shardé Davis: then I know that you know in
terms of the repercussions that they might
come at, you know,
Shardé Davis: that there's like that might
try, they're going to have to come up, be
a little bit more strategic
Shardé Davis: if they even go and try to,
try to, if there's any backlash for me speaking
out.
Shardé Davis: So I would just consider that
as well. I have seen, for example, graduate
students where they,
Shardé Davis: they, they could probably there,
they could probably spend a little bit more
time in terms of
Shardé Davis: research and teaching, they
don't necessarily have an established record,
but they were
Shardé Davis: very much provoking them there,
and it didn't turn out well for them because
of
Shardé Davis: the backlash and they just
didn't have a record to stand on. So take
it as you will.
Shardé Davis: But I know that that is a strategy
that has very much work for me.
Christina Couch: And what do you think about
the role of tenure and supporting systemic
racism in the academy?
Christina Couch: And if you feel tenure plays
a role, what do you think about getting rid
of the tenure process?
Mareena Robinson Snowden: James do you want
to go?. I'm not even up for tenure. I’m
not even going for it. You have it, so do
you want to talk about it?
James Mickens: The rumors are true. So I recently
got tenure last year, thank you.
James Mickens: Thank you. I think that tenure
is kind of a double edged sword. And this
gets back to some
James Mickens: of our earlier conversations
about what is the additional burden or the
additional load
James Mickens: that you bear as a person of
color, and as a Black person in particular
when you have to juggle all of that, you
James Mickens: know, with publisher or perish
and you have to teach and do all those kinds
of things? I think that
James Mickens: you know, so tenure is good
in a sense that, you know, if you get tenure,
then that does give you
James Mickens: the freedom to be more outspoken
about certain things getting some of Shardé’s
points
James Mickens: as well. You know, so once
you sort of have that credential and just
to be frank, it's a credential.
James Mickens: Right. We live in a credentialed
society and one reason why it's hard for grad
students to speak
James Mickens: up about these things is because
you don't have that credential, which says,
Ph.D., I'm a doctor. You’re
James Mickens: getting there, but you're not
there yet, you know, and so what you often
find is that, you know, if
James Mickens: you lack those credentials,
that, that sort of puts you in a greater position
of danger if you will to
James Mickens: speak out about these things.
I think that the, and this is an unfortunate
but I think this is a
James Mickens: reality of the current academic
market, is that as I was mentioning before,
even in engineering,
James Mickens: it's a social science. You
know, you’ve got to go to conferences. You’ve
got to talk to people. You've got
James Mickens: to do some of that networking,
and in fact, you have to do a little bit extra
networking because
James Mickens: you know, when I was talking
about people thinking about who to invite
to a colloquium and, you know,
James Mickens: conveniently, you know, Black
people don't get mentioned or women don't
get mentioned, you
James Mickens: know, it's not in many cases
because of sort of like quote-unquote big
O Overt racism. It's just
James Mickens: these systemic problems that
are there. And so when you think about tenure,
you know, how does that work
James Mickens: at most schools, when you go
up for tenure, you’ve got to get a ton of
letters. Right, you get, other
James Mickens: professors in your field have
to write these letters that basically say
this person deserves
James Mickens: tenure. This is like some medieval
stuff, man. There's like trying to get into
like a spice guild back
James Mickens: in, like, you know, 15th century
Italy or something like this. Right. And so
you know as an engineer, you
James Mickens: think, okay, what's my work
back plan then?So, you know, I need to eventually
get, you know, some number
James Mickens: of letters, let's say 10 letters,
15 letters, how do I go about getting those
those letters?
James Mickens: You know, how do I act intentionally?
How do I send preprints to other professors,
things like that? How do I
James Mickens: go to other schools and give
presentations, things like this? So I think
that in that sense, there,
James Mickens: you know, getting tenure can
be more difficult when you're a person of
color. I think if you get it
James Mickens: it's sort of incumbent upon
you to try to use that position of, to be
frank, power to advocate for some
James Mickens: of these issues. Now perhaps
the other part of the question is what does
it mean when you've got
James Mickens: these, you know, older people,
shall we say, who are tenured who may be not
as forward-looking as
James Mickens: other people that we might
be able to think about? And that's hard. You
know that's hard.
James Mickens: And, and those those folks,
you know, as I was mentioning earlier,
James Mickens: I like to think about people
as sort of like evil and wicked and can't
be reasoned with,
James Mickens: and I have a set of strategies
for dealing with them and then it's sort of
like
James Mickens: incompetent or ignorant. Right.
And my advisor told me something that was
really,
James Mickens: really changed my life. I was
angry about something that someone that had
done to me
James Mickens: and he said, never, never ascribed
to malice, what can be explained by incompetence.
And so this is
James Mickens: not to say that they're not
actively evil people out there. But I think
if you have that attitude,
James Mickens: that actually makes it easier
to deal with, for example, some of these older
tenured professors
James Mickens: who seem like they're acting
just willy nilly, just they’re like Sauron
from Lord of the Rings,
James Mickens: but really they're from a different
era, perhaps, or maybe they have blind spots
that you can help
James Mickens: them with. And that, and I
realized that when I say that that's putting
a disproportionate burden
James Mickens: on the people who are disenfranchised
to have to teach people about things. And
that's a real burden.
James Mickens: So I want to be clear about
that, just in the way that Mareena talked
about you. You can put yourself in
James Mickens: peril by speaking up. It is
exhausting to have to explain some of these
things to well-intentioned
James Mickens: but confused people. But one
thing that I've seen at least personally my
career and when
James Mickens: I look at the careers of my
friends and other folks is that,
James Mickens: you know, Black scholars who've
been able to, to sort of thread that needle
and on the one hand, sort of speak with some
of that fire
James Mickens: and point out things that are
problematic in the ivory tower, but also build
coalitions, also
James Mickens: create a sense of community,
not just amongst other Black scholars, but
amongst you know
James Mickens: white scholars, amongst not
just women, but men as well. Those people
tend to be the most effective.
James Mickens: And so, you know, I would keep
all that in mind in thinking about how it
is you want to
James Mickens: sort of structure your career.
What do you do? What don’t you do?
Christina Couch: This person asks, I'm curious
how the panelists have been able to quantify
what I call the invisible
Christina Couch: tax of being a Black faculty
member and / or a doctoral student. I started
documenting literally
Christina Couch: every student mentoring conversation,
each token committee assignment, any offensive
Christina Couch: remark from non-BIPOC colleague,
slight from leadership, almost to the point
of therapy.
Christina Couch: How do you recommend we start
going beyond simply holding receipts in the
review process?
Mareena Robinson Snowden: So that is a really
interesting question, the way that it was
framed. Um, when I when you first
Mareena Robinson Snowden: started reading
it, Christina, you know, the idea of receipts.
I always think about insurance policies
Mareena Robinson Snowden: right, and and I
think you expect the worst because you want
to be ready. You're, you're surprised
Mareena Robinson Snowden: when the amazing
things happen, but you want to think about
all the potential outcomes. Right.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: And in my own Ph.D.
experience, it got to the point where I also
had to keep receipts, right,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: and had to write
minutes after every single advisement meeting
so that it was on the record
Mareena Robinson Snowden: what was understood
to James's point about bringing a paper and
writing down concrete
Mareena Robinson Snowden: and specific expectations.
Um, but I think there is a, my question would
be what is the
Mareena Robinson Snowden: intention behind
the receipts? Right. What is, what is the,
what, what, what does the quantification,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: what end does the
quantification serve right? So if you're trying
to have the receipts
Mareena Robinson Snowden: because your department
has a history or a track record of treating
students and faculty
Mareena Robinson Snowden: of color in less
than above the board way, and you want to
have kind of a record of that
Mareena Robinson Snowden: if things ever go
left, that's one thing. Right. Um, if you
are trying, if you're keeping receipts
Mareena Robinson Snowden: as a processing
mechanism for yourself, you know, but the
goal at the end of it is kind of a healthy
Mareena Robinson Snowden: outlook on the situation,
that’s another thing. For me, I think, you
know,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: not all asks on
your, on your time are inherently negative,
right.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: There are some people
I want to mentor. There's a lot that I get
out
Mareena Robinson Snowden: of that a relationship
or that participation on a task force or being
consulted
Mareena Robinson Snowden: for things right.
So I hope that we're not giving the impression
that that work
Mareena Robinson Snowden: writ large should
be shied away from right, but I think if you're
looking for balance
Mareena Robinson Snowden: sometimes writing
it out, can be helpful. Right. That was something
that a mentor told me.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: Write down all the
obligations that you have and put it on a
whiteboard where you have to see it so
Mareena Robinson Snowden: that when somebody
comes up to you and asked you to do the next
thing, you can remember, because this is
Mareena Robinson Snowden: where I fail, I
forget all the other things I've committed
to right. So then I commit to the next
Mareena Robinson Snowden: thing, not knowing
that something is already in its place right.
So that's the intention of
Mareena Robinson Snowden: the receipt. It
can be helpful, but I think just, I mean,
I'm curious. I wish this could
Mareena Robinson Snowden: be a back and forth
on what the intention of your detailed receipts
are, and understanding
Mareena Robinson Snowden: if that intention
is serving you versus kind of focusing your
mind on something that,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: you know, might,
might be keeping you in in a not so helpful
place, if that makes sense.
Christina Couch: The next question is how
do we combat seeing Blackness as a monolith
if we
Christina Couch: are often encouraged to code
switch and white higher education places.
James Mickens: The code switching burdens.
You can tell by the pregnant pause from everyone,
James Mickens: we're like, oh man, how do
we address this one? So, so the code switching
burden is real.
James Mickens: I think that there's, there's,
sort of like a practical reality of, of, of,
sort of like how do, once
James Mickens: again speak to power, or even
people who are your peers or people who are
sort of, quote-unquote, you
James Mickens: know, junior to you. I think
it is important for anyone. Not just white
people, for Black people,
James Mickens: to anyone, men, women, to be
able to understand who their audience is.
Right and understand how to
James Mickens: phrase things in a way that
will help your message resonate with that
other person. Right, I mean like
James Mickens: Barack Obama was a hilarious
example of this, right, because you know you
can go on Twitter and type in,
James Mickens: you know, “Barack Obama speaking
like he's Black” and get a whole set of
funny videos you can get a
James Mickens: you know, “Barack Obama speaking
like he's white” and get a whole different
set of funny videos
James Mickens: So, you know, it's something
that I think a lot of scholars of color struggle
with because they want
James Mickens: to always be authentic, you
know, but in some cases like be speaking in
your authentic voice
James Mickens: may not be received well by
the audience. And I think one of the most
important things to
James Mickens: understand, like in public
speaking and whenever you're in a situation
where you're trying to
James Mickens: be perceived as a person with
authority, and that is one of the biggest
challenges for
James Mickens: scholars of color. Are you
perceived as someone with authority? Because
you will not automatically be
James Mickens: given that authority, and particularly
in science. You know, technical authority.
That’s a phrase you
James Mickens: hear thrown around a lot. You
know, this person's in authority on X. They're
an authority on Y.
James Mickens: And as a person of color, in
particular is a Black person, you will oftentimes
not be afforded
James Mickens: that automatic authority that
might be conferred to a white person who has
your same level of
James Mickens: background, your same publication
record. And so I think an unfortunate
James Mickens: sort of consequence of that
is that you will sometimes have to tweak your,
your message a bit
James Mickens: or change the way that you
talk. And this is sort of just as a practical
thing, you know.
James Mickens: I think about this as an engineer.
Right. So I like telling jokes. I like being
funny, but I also
James Mickens: know that there are certain
career goals I have that are furthered by
me first being understood as
James Mickens: a technical authority, and
then only second being understood as someone
you want to hang out with
James Mickens: after the talk, or things like
that. So I think this is a really important
example of how you
James Mickens: have to know your audience.
This is not me you necessarily have to self
censor. That's a different thing.
James Mickens: You know, I think that hopefully
wherever you are in life, whether you're a
workplace environment or some a personal environment,
James Mickens: you should feel comfortable
saying that things that are on your
James Mickens: mind. But I think from the
practical perspective, it is important to
try to understand the perspective
James Mickens: of the person that you're talking
to and in academia, this is particularly the
case because you will
James Mickens: oftentimes encounter well intentioned
people who don't get it. And that's like a
big chunk of the
James Mickens: resistance that, at least I've
seen personally, my friends who are scholars
of color encounter.
James Mickens: It's not that the person doesn't
want to help. It’s that they don't fully
understand the scope
James Mickens: of the problem, or they don't
fully understand why the current mechanisms
aren't good enough.
James Mickens: And so, once again, it is a
burden to be an educator. It is difficult
to have to feel like you need to
James Mickens: justify things that you believe
are innately true and that you have experienced
as personally true.
James Mickens: But I mean I think that is
something that I see successful Black scholars
do, that there is sort
James Mickens: of like this, in a sense this
extra educational effort they do to try to
make people, to allow
James Mickens: people to meet them halfway,
if you will. To sort of build that rhetorical
bridge where both of
James Mickens: the people can meet and then
they can say, “Okay this is actually a real
problem
that I understand.”
Mareena Robinson Snowden: So listen this is
such an interesting question and it's
Mareena Robinson Snowden: I agree with you,
James, and at the same time, I like how you
frame it in terms of a practical
Mareena Robinson Snowden: question and this
idea of, you know, I haven't ever thought
about code switching in relation to
Mareena Robinson Snowden: tailoring for your
audience, right. Because that is very well
understood, particularly in any kind
Mareena Robinson Snowden: of scholastic, technical
presentations, things like that. Right. Like,
you want to tailor your slides to
Mareena Robinson Snowden: the level of your
audience, whether it's a general audience,
you would present it one way or if it's
Mareena Robinson Snowden: a very technical
audience who knows your narrow field, you
would present it a different way.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: It's interesting.
It's almost. It's almost like how you speak
in different settings. So if you're in
Mareena Robinson Snowden: a technical presentation,
that's fine, but I think we have to also leave
space for acknowledging that
Mareena Robinson Snowden: in more general
engagement, when I'm at the water cooler or
I'm in the break room or
Mareena Robinson Snowden: something, you know,
we should not give the system a pass in making
us feel like we must
Mareena Robinson Snowden: speak in a certain
way or use certain vocabulary, right. Like
when you when you are not with your
Mareena Robinson Snowden: engineer hat on
and giving a technical talk, you know, and
you are just Mareena or Shardé or James,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: you should be able
to speak how you speak, right, and part of
that power comes from, my dad
Mareena Robinson Snowden: says to me all the
time, don't focus on the form, focus on the
substance, right. What am I saying?
Mareena Robinson Snowden: And is what I'm
saying correct? Rhen who cares about how I'm
saying it in this informal
Mareena Robinson Snowden: interaction right?
Now if I'm in a technical talk, that’s a
different environment right, but I don't
Mareena Robinson Snowden: want our audience
to leave without the acknowledgement that
you should be able to bring
Mareena Robinson Snowden: your vernacular,
your inflection. Women get told this all the
time — Make sure you
bring your inflection down. Think about your
inflection. Like the amount of thought behind
Mareena Robinosn Snowden: the scenes that
has to go into how I'm speaking, how am I
gonna have any energy
Mareena Robinson Snowden: left to focus on
the damn nuclear engineering? So like we have
to leave space
Mareena Robinson Snowden: for that truth as
well. Yes, there is tailoring to your audience
and I totally agree with that.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: I love that framing.
And in less formal interactions, you should
feel empowered and you should push
Mareena Robinson Snowden: against the system
to not focus on the form, but focus on the
substance of what you're saying.
Shardé Davis: I'm glad you said that, Mareena.
I think you brought up a good point. And as
I was listening to
Shardé Davis: the question, and it was something
I kind of gleaned from it was kind of a burden
that somehow we
Shardé Davis: as Blackademics carry in thinking
that our behavior is somehow going to change
how
Shardé Davis: what they, our white colleagues
view us. So thinking we don’t, I heard how
code
Shardé Davis: switching or not and perhaps
how that is going to impact our, our white
colleagues seeing us as
Shardé Davis: a monolith. But unfortunately,
we could code switch. We could not code switch.
We could use inflections.
Shardé Davis: We could show up in our Ankara
or our kente cloth. I could show up with a
press and curl, or,
Shardé Davis: you know, my natural kinky
curl. Their cognitive processing is their
cognitive processing,
Shardé Davis: right, and it's going to vary
from white person to white person and that
their own particular journey and
Shardé Davis: where they are at in life.
And honestly that's really doesn't have much
to do with our own behavior,
Shardé Davis: right, because anti-Black racism,
it's systemic. It's not us, baby. It's them.
Right. And so,
Shardé Davis: I think, and what I’m, you
know, hearing from Mareena and from James
is that I think we have to
Shardé Davis: really keep that in mind and
give ourselves some grace right in allowing
us to just be able to
Shardé Davis: show up and spaces in ways
that we need to show up, in ways that we deem
correct and necessary
Shardé Davis: right and authentic to who
we are, um, because yeah there's not much
that we can really say
Shardé Davis: or try to go and change. If
a white person is going to see us as a monolithic
kind of Black
Shardé Davis: culture, then they're really
not going to change from that unless they
go, again, they have their
Shardé Davis: own process and journey to
where they are starting to recognize that
those are beliefs that they hold
Shardé Davis: and they're trying to move
from that. But it's not likely going to change
from you code switching or not.
Christina Couch: So this is our last question,
thank everybody for being here. The questions
Christina Couch: have been wonderful. And
I'm sorry that we can't get to all of them.
Christina Couch: Christina Couch: So I'm actually
going to kind of combine a few questions here.
We've had a number of questions
Christina Couch: along the lines of the structure
of academia and how that influences systemic
racism.
Christina Couch: Given systemic racism in
academia, how might the structure of a Ph.D.
degree be changed to be more
Christina Couch: equitable. I'm going to kind
of broaden that out and say the structure
of academia in general.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: So I'll take a first
stab and then Shardé and James, you guys
definitely correct me. So
Mareena Robinson Snowden: I think one of the
things that works against equity in the Ph.D.
process, specifically,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: is all of the opaqueness
right, and I understand that there is a purpose,
at least in theory
Mareena Robinson Snowden: that the opaqueness
serves but when you're in the system, it feels
more like the opaqueness is to
Mareena Robinson Snowden: serve as kind of
a protection for the department more than
it is in service of anything to do with
Mareena Robinson Snowden: the student. So
this idea that, you know, the essence of the
Ph.D. is creating new knowledge.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: Right. And the fact
that, it’s similar with a tenure track,
you don't know where that bar is.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: You know it's up
there, but they're not going to tell you exactly
what you have to do in order
Mareena Robinson Snowden: to get that next
promotion, whether it's the Ph.D. itself or
the actual tenure appointment. Right.
Mareena Robinson Snowden: But, but in practice,
um, because it isn't very clear about how
this process works, you see, particularly
Mareena Robinson Snowden: students of color,
and particularly Black students falling through
the cracks, right, for things that
Mareena Robinson Snowden: don't have to be
justified because the process is so opaque
right. So that's what I meant by
Mareena Robinson Snowden: students who applied
for a Ph.D., but for whatever reason are leaving
with the masters. Right. You talk
Mareena Robinson Snowden: about the qualifying
exam process right. We have to look at that
system. How does that system affect
Mareena Robinson Snowden: the attrition rate?
And then who in that attrition rate is actually
leaving. Because, my hypothesis
Mareena Robinson Snowden: would be that that
is also not equitable. Everybody is not leaving
at the same rate, right, and you
Mareena Robinson Snowden: have to look at
that over time. So I think, you know, we need
to as an institution or as a field,
Mareena Robinson Snowden: we need to try where
possible, to shed some light and try to put
some more formal
Mareena Robinson Snowden: structure on these
points of evaluation. Yes, you may not put
a five-point bullet list about
Mareena Robinson Snowden: exactly what it's
going to take to get a Ph.D., but you need
to give people something to hold on to
Mareena Robinson Snowden: so that when there
is that problem, which often is for students
of color, they have a ground
Mareena Robinson Snowden: to stand on right.
They have a way to challenge the department.
And it's not just, “oh, we got in the room
Mareena Robinson Snowden: and we decided you're
off the island,” which is like what it feels
like. And, and when you look at who is
Mareena Robinson Snowden: getting thrown off
the island, more often than not, you know,
it disproportionately affects students
Mareena Robinson Snowden: of color, and particularly
American-born students of color, because that
is something
Mareena Robinson Snowden: that we don't acknowledge
right. When not only do we define diversity
with respect to gender, but we
Mareena Robinson Snowden: often point to our
international students as the beacon of our
diversity, right, ignoring the
Mareena Robinson Snowden: historical context
of racism in America. Right. And why no American
students are able to get into our,
Mareena Robinson Snowden:our organizations
in our institution. So we have to look at
those those systems.
Shardé Davis: Yes, yes, yes, yes. And related
to that, I think about the hidden curriculum
Shardé Davis: in academia and in terms of
ways to make it a bit more equitable is to
Shardé Davis: acknowledge that there's a
hidden curriculum and to find ways, even at
a departmental in
Shardé Davis: terms of the programs and colleges,
to find ways to communicate to teach curriculum
Shardé Davis: to your, your BIPOC students.
For example, I think about writing. The English
language is white.
Shardé Davis: It's white American language,
right. It's created by white folks thinking
about Black
Shardé Davis: folks, for example, we are
a multilingual people. The English language
is not, reading and
Shardé Davis: writing in English is not,
does not come easy or it's not easier. How
should I put this? Relative to
Shardé Davis: our white counterparts, we
very much struggle as a Black people with
our, with that language reading
Shardé Davis: and writing because we're multilingual
individual people. And so because of that,
Shardé Davis: academia really needs to recognize
that academic writing is A) technical,
Shardé Davis: so therefore, it needs to be
taught about just the basics, the mechanics
of academic writing.
Shardé Davis: But then also that there are
individuals, for example, who have gone through
the pre K through 12
Shardé Davis: educational system who have
not been taught, right, the basics of writing.
And so there are
Shardé Davis: assumptions that we have about
how Ph.D. students are supposed to show up
in the program and how
Shardé Davis: hey're supposed to perform,
and again, this kind of curriculum that people
are assuming that they know
Shardé Davis: or were taught and they may
not have been taught. Even thinking about
the basics of
Shardé Davis: research, right. Even though
individuals may have some research experience
coming from
Shardé Davis: coming from let's say their
undergraduate or masters institution, they
may not have been sat
Shardé Davis: down and talked kind of the
ABCs or the one-beats of research and what
it looks like.
Shardé Davis: Again, there can be a disadvantage
at play for some of our BIPOC students as
they're moving
Shardé Davis: through the program. So I think
we have that, we have to recognize that we're
all not starting out
Shardé Davis: at the same level right, and
that there is kind of a hidden network where
social capital
Shardé Davis: and information is being transferred
among particular groups of people in ways
that is different from,
Shardé Davis: again our BIPOC students, and
to find a way to make sure that they get that
information as well.
James Mickens: Yeah I think that, I think
that what both of you just said was really
about the importance
James Mickens: of mentorship, too. Because,
you know, when you talk about the hidden curriculum
or the, this sort of
James Mickens: implicit set of skills that
people are assumed to have, I mean, it's not
just about the hidden
James Mickens: curriculum. It's also about
the fact that, you know, oftentimes the rules
are used to punish the people,
James Mickens: the people in power want to
punish, but these rules are oftentimes not,
you know, set in stone, you know.
James Mickens: Take quals exams, for example.
I know you know many schools, you know, if
the department likes you,
James Mickens: you can fail your quals and
“well, we’ll give you another shot.”
If the school doesn't like you,
James Mickens: You fail, half the time and
“I don't like your progress, man. You know,
you're a little bit weak there.”
James Mickens: And so we all know examples
of this. And so that's one place where mentorship
is so important
James Mickens: because a mentor who knows
how the institution works can set your expectations
correctly for, like,
James Mickens: this is really a rule that
you have to follow. Here's how you really
get evaluated.
James Mickens: This is really what, for example,
the faculty market looks like. This is what
they're
James Mickens: looking for in terms of a resume.
So I think a lot of these, these, these issues,
a lot of them are related
James Mickens: to this issue of mentorship
and so I think one of the big things that
universities could do
James Mickens: to improve the outcomes for
Black Ph.D. students and Black faculty as
well as make sure there
James Mickens: are strong mentoring networks
in place to explain some of this hidden knowledge
that is so critical
James Mickens: for actually succeeding, you
know. And like talking about, you know, the
extra burdens that you know
James Mickens: scholars of color have, you
know, which committee memberships can you
say no to? There are actually
James Mickens: many of them, you can say no
to and there are no bad effects on you. There
are some you should
James Mickens: not do that for. Which ones?
You know, it’s part of this hidden knowledge.
So I think the mentorship
James Mickens: aspect is really key to making
sure that we have Black scholars succeeding
in academia.
Christina Couch: [Silence]
Seth Mnookin: You're, you're Chris, you're,
you're, I think you've cut out a little bit.
Christina Couch: Hi. Sorry. That's Seth Mnookin,
our director. Can you hear me now?
Christina Couch: Great. Okay. One more time
then. Thank you all so much for being here.
If you would like to see more events like
this sign up for our
Christina Couch: mailing list at commforum.mit.edu.
There’s a link in the chat. Thank you to
Radius at MIT and the MIT
Christina Couch: Governance Lab for supporting
events like this. This was a really delightful
thing, so thank
Christina Couch: all of our panelists for
carving out time today to do this. Thank you
so much and have a nice night, everyone.